ja fast jeden tag berichten wer hierbei
bild über spektakuläre kriminalfälle und
immer wieder stellen auch wir uns die
frage warum meine kollegin lena zander
ging jetzt diesem warum nach und hat
einen mörder besucht ich habe in meinem
leben viele dummheiten gemacht als
mensch als katholik aber das war
sicherlich viel schlimmer das hat alles
in meinem leben überschattet
immer wieder erzählt mir robert p nun
dass er die tat ja nicht allein begangen
habe rechtfertigung eines doppelmörders
vor der tat haben wir auch drogen
genommen wir waren betäubt es war eine
tragödie
wir haben kein überfall geplant wir
wollten nur den safe stehlen
nur einen diebstahl machen als ich den
mann in den keller schleppte fühlte ich
heuer neu und doch ist es eine tat die
nie zu verzeihen ist wird gott ihm
verzeihen will ich von robert p wissen
ob gott mir die tat verziehen hat gottes
barmherzig bezahle dann aber ich werde
mir selbst diese tat nie verzeihen hier
und jetzt ist sie bei mir zu gast hier
im studio meine bild kollegin lena
sander lena tut morgen wie war es für
dich der moment ist so zum ersten mal
auf diese mörder daraus was hast du da
gefühlt vorwerk war ich natürlich auch
ein bisschen aufgeregt angespannt weil
man weiß ja nie wie so ein gespräch auch
laufen wird ich hatte im vorfeld schon
gehört während des prozesses dass er als
der richter ihn nicht ausreden lassen
seinen kopf auf die tischplatte knallte
und wir wissen alle dass verbrechen es
wirklich ein grausames dementsprechend
war ich wirklich ein wenig nervös als
damit dann gegenüber saß und ich meine
ersten fragen stellte dachte ich auch
wissen ja auch nicht vielleicht steht da
gleich auf und geht aber im laufe des
gespräches also sehr offene worden und
wir konnten uns wirklich gut unterhalten
wenn man sich das so vorstellt man
trifft ein mörder da haben wir ja alle
auch bestimmte bilder im kopf wie die
dann aussehen und oft heißt es dann ja
der mensch war ganz unauffällig man
hätte ihnen das gar nicht zugetraut war
das in diesem fall auch so gut ist es
natürlich schwer zu sagen du bist ein
mörder du bist kein mörder wenn man
jemanden nur einfach sieht in diesem
fall kann ich wirklich sagen mir ist ein
mann begegnet platz
mit stahlblauen augen also wenn er mich
angeschaut hat ich habe ihn gefragt sind
sie ein mörder und dann macht er eine
kurze pause schaute mich an und sagte
wirklich ins gesicht nein
und das sind auch wirklich so momente wo
man erst mal erschüttert außerdem ist er
wahnsinnig durchtrainiert trug ein
kurzes t-shirt mann hat seine muskeln
gesehen die adern zeichneten sich ab ob
das jetzt das typische bild eines
mörders ist natürlich immer dahin gesagt
aber am er war schon jemand wo man denkt
dieser augen also die waren die waren
wirklich sehr sehr stechend und die sind
auch hängen geblieben die blicke befreit
es ihnen sind sie einen mörder und er
sagt nein seine tat ist ja nun aber auch
bewiesen deswegen sitzt er ja im
gefängnis wie reflektiert er über seine
tat
obwohl er sagt dass er kein mörder ist
hatte ich schon das gefühl dass er
reflektiert über seine taten auch
spricht und auch denkt das ist natürlich
ganz schwierig auch zu sagen er war
nicht alleine er hat dieses verbrechen
nicht alleine begangen ist man noch zwei
weitere männer mit dabei einmal sein
neffe und ein freund der beiden und mehr
da was gemacht hat das hat das gericht
entschieden es gericht hat gesagt er ist
der kopf der bande
er hat wirklich auch die schlimmste
strafe in deutschland die höchststrafe
bekommen besondere schwere der schuld
anschließende sicherungsverwahrung
und das ist natürlich auch etwas
nürnberg wie spricht er denn über seine
opfer konntest du da erkennen
es waren momente der ruhe auf jeden fall
spürbar
also den fokus angehen im gespräch auch
wirklich auf ihn und seine gefühlswelt
gelegt deswegen war das jetzt nicht so
das zentrale thema aber er hat zum
beispiel erzählt wie er den mann der ja
auch aufgrund dieses amt bereits
verstorben ist in den keller schleppte
weil die wollten in diesem keller den
tresor knacken
und er sagte der fiel ihm immer wieder
aus der hand
da hatte ich schon das gefühl und viel
dann wirklich mit dem kopf auch auf die
treppenstufen und ich hatte das gefühl
dass das vielleicht auch etwas ist ja wo
er versucht auch ein bisschen abstand zu
dem ganzen zu gewinnen er sagte selber
wir waren auf drogen da ist man vorher
wahrscheinlich mitgenommen da ist es
sowieso noch mal was ganz anderes aber
in dem moment sagt er selber habe er
reue gespürt und das kam für mich auch
nicht unglaubwürdig rüber das haben wir
auch in seinem beitrag gesehen der mann
bezeichnet sich als gläubiger katholik
wie geht er denn damit jetzt um
ich glaube dass es viele
ich wahnsinnig schwierig er betonte
immer wieder ich glaube an gott ich bin
so erzogen ich bin getauft ich habe
meine kommunion gehabt meine eltern
waren streng
er kommt aus polen in polen ist
natürlich auch ist das eine religion und
eine ja eine erziehungssache
letztendlich auch und er betet jeden tag
zu gott sagt er bittet um verzeihung er
betet auch für die beiden opfer die
gestorben sind dass es ihnen gut geht
und ich fragte ihn auch wie stellen sie
sich denn ihr dasein nach dem tod vor
und dann sagt ja auch nur ich weiß ich
komme in die hölle und gott ob denkt
verteilen wird er hofft es aber er
selbst sagt er wird sich diese tat
wirklich nie verzeihen konnte er dir
denn oder sich selber denn die frage
nach dem warum beantworten
das ist natürlich auch eine schwierige
frage was treibt jemanden an also er
sagte zu mir dass sie gar nicht
vorhatten diesen mord diese morde zu
begehen sondern dass sie es wirklich auf
das geld abgesehen hatten der mann hatte
schulden
der wollte das schnelle geld machen weil
dieser frau wo er eingebrochen ist
wussten sie da ist etwas zu holen war
seine schwester vorher den man der dame
der das haus gehörte gepflegt hat bis er
verstorben ist und diesen tipp bekommen
hatte
klar gelte es ein großes motiv vorher
warfen sich wie gesagt rein und hat noch
nicht damit gerechnet dass diese beiden
übernachtungsgäste da sind was da jetzt
genau in deren köpfen vorgegangen
das ist natürlich schwierig zu sagen er
selber sagt auch es ging alles schnell
es war explosionsartig die hatten hätten
gar nicht wirklich darüber nachgedacht
es sei etwas im effekt das gericht hat
anders entschieden und deswegen da jetzt
auch dementsprechend im gefängnis